Just to give you some additional information on true silver, you'll notice when the program
is running, you will have the blue light on the effect side because we're set the bath
for this output.
But the green light is very dim, in fact you might not see it at all.
But it is working, it is generating silver.
If you're not sure what you can do is you can pull this lid off, you'll see I have a separation
on the probes.
If you actually touch these probes, this light gets bright at that point.
Don't try to generate silver this way, you won't get anything.
So re-center the probe, keep it centered like this, put it back in the jar, and off you
go.
So that's one way you can demonstrate you have continuity in here.
The light is dim because virtually the still water has little or no conductivity until
it starts to process and then this light will brighten up slightly after that.
Now when the silver is done in process, you are provided with these little bottles here.
And frankly I don't even feel their mind, but if you want to feel it, we do provide some
filters and you got a little filter there.
These are nothing but coffee filters.
You can put this in here and then you can slowly pour your product in into these two honest
bottles.
It takes a little bit, it'll come down, I'm just kind of letting it filter down there.
At that point I can pull this out, snap on the sprayer there, and this is pretty cool
stuff.
You can spray this under your tongue, you can spray it in your eyes if they're itchy or you
can spray it under your arms to deal with a perspiration problem.
So it's a pretty neat product.
But about 10 to 20 sprays every few hours under the tongue will help it absorb into the
bloodstream, bypass the stomach a little bit.
And I will let you know if you take a lot of silver, it takes some probiotics with it because
this will kill good bacteria as well as the bad stuff.
So silver is a cool product.
It's a multi-spectrum killer, it was used before antibiotics way back in the turn of the
last century.
It's not a perfect item or this is all we would need but it is a very, very good product
that is still in use today.
In fact, it's silver is even being used to wind medical gloves that are used in surgery
because silver virtually is anti-viral, antibacterial, antifungal.
It kills everything that comes in contact with it.
So hope you enjoy this product and here again, you're making this for pennies.
Some people actually will dump the whole jar in their hot tub and here again it will help
sterilize the water and keep everything clean without the use of harsh chemicals.